This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's a video on YouTube you might have seen. It has nearly 200 million views. In this video, a pair of twin brothers are standing in a kitchen, having a little chat. These twin brothers, a diaper clad, babies. A diaper clad. Babies. Now, if this video featured 10-year-old twins or adult twins, I guarantee you it wouldn't have gone viral.
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你可能在 YouTube 上看过一个视频。它的观看量近 2 亿次。在这个视频里，一对双胞胎兄弟正站在厨房里，聊着天。这对双胞胎兄弟，还穿着尿布，是婴儿。穿着尿布。婴儿。如果这个视频的主角是 10 岁的双胞胎或成年双胞胎，我向你保证，它绝对不会火。
What makes this video special is that we have no clue what these babies are saying. To us non-babies, it sounds like Gobletyygook. Cute, mysterious, gobbledygook. Here at Hidden Brain, we love trying to understand the puzzles and contradictions of human behavior. But we spend most of our time talking about the older members of the human race. Today, we focus on the younger set. The much younger set. I find babies are so impressive. We can't really ask them what they're thinking.
这个视频的特别之处在于，我们根本听不懂这些婴儿在说些什么。对于我们这些不是婴儿的人来说，这听起来就像是胡言乱语。可爱、神秘的胡言乱语。在 Hidden Brain，我们喜欢试图理解人类行为中的谜题和矛盾。但我们大部分时间都在谈论人类中年龄较长的人。今天，我们将目光聚焦于年龄较小的那群人。小得多的一群人。我发现婴儿非常令人惊叹。我们无法真正问他们在想什么。
We have to come up with clever ways of figuring out what's going on in their little brains. We'll meet some of the researchers trying to decipher the behavior of babies. Oh, oh, that's a ball? Yep, you're right. Do babies understand us when we're talking to them? That's a ball, you try to say ball, it's great. And how babies communicate even if they don't have words. Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da. The language of babies, this week, on Hidden Brain.
我们必须想出聪明的办法，来弄清楚他们的小脑瓜里在想些什么。我们将结识一些试图破译婴儿行为的研究人员。哦，哦，那是一个球？是的，你说得对。当我们和婴儿说话时，他们能听懂我们的话吗？那是球，你试着说球，太棒了。还有婴儿即使不会说话是如何进行交流的。哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒。婴儿的语言，本周，在 Hidden Brain。
Hi, I'm Laura Sreli. When Laura was in college, she spent her summer vacations back home in Subry, Ontario. Like five hours north of Toronto. And she worked at the Magical Nook, a daycare center. It was a large center that had different age groups. So there was like a baby room and a toddler room, preschooler, school-aged children,
嗨，我是劳拉·斯雷利。劳拉上大学时，暑假都会回到她位于安大略省萨德里的老家。大约在多伦多以北五小时车程的地方。她在一家名为“魔法角落”的日托中心工作。那是一个很大的中心，有不同的年龄组。所以有婴儿室、幼儿室、学龄前儿童室、学龄儿童室，
probably about 100 children total. But my favorite room was the toddler room for sure. Laura's job was to help the teachers of the center engage with the kids and enforce the rules. The music was an essential tool. We would sing wheels on the bass. Old McDonald's. If we didn't sing the clean up songs the preschoolers then I don't think anything would have ever gotten cleaned up. But as soon as we started it seemed to be the trick to convince them that yes, they were willing to put their toys away.
加起来大概有 100 个孩子。但我最喜欢的绝对是幼儿室。劳拉的工作是帮助中心的老师与孩子们互动并执行规则。音乐是一个必不可少的工具。我们会唱《公交车上的轮子》。《老麦克唐纳》。如果我们不唱学龄前儿童的收拾玩具歌，我想什么东西都永远收拾不干净。但只要我们一唱起歌，这似乎就是说服他们——是的，他们愿意把玩具收起来的绝招。
Laura regularly found herself in awe of the toddlers. One little kid who I had a good connection with, she grabbed my hand and brought me over to the little slide, and she really wanted to go down the slide, you could tell. So I helped her up the little stairs and I caught her at the bottom of the slide and all the rest of the toddlers in this playground just looked over and saw her and looked at each other and then ran over to the slide and formed a cute little line up waiting her turn for me to help them down. Laura's days at the magical knuck are now over. After graduating college, she went on to earn her PhD in Psychology, Neuroscience and Behavior.
劳拉经常发现自己对幼儿赞叹不已。有一个我和她关系很好的小孩，她拉着我的手把我带到滑梯旁，你能看得出来她非常想滑滑梯。所以我帮她爬上小楼梯，并在滑梯底部接住了她。这个游乐场里的所有其他幼儿都转头看到了她，互相看了一眼，然后跑到滑梯旁，排成了一个可爱的小队伍，等着我帮他们滑下来。劳拉在“魔法角落”的日子现在已经结束了。大学毕业后，她继续深造，获得了心理学、神经科学和行为学博士学位。
She's now a postdoc at the University of Toronto, Mrs. Saga, and her work focuses on early childhood development. With years of knowledge now under her belt, she looks back on that moment at the slide and sees it as a form of communication. You know, in order for kids to look around and see what their peers are doing and to understand the goals that are embedded in those activities and to then realize that they need to follow the social construct
她现在是多伦多大学密西沙加分校的博士后，她的工作重点是幼儿早期发展。带着多年积累的知识，她回想起在滑梯旁的那一刻，并将其视为一种交流形式。你知道的，为了让孩子们环顾四周，看看同龄人都在做什么，并理解这些活动中蕴含的目标，然后意识到他们需要遵循排队的社会结构，
of lining up. It seems like a super simple thing, but there's a lot of understanding about themselves realize that they need to follow the social construct of lining up. It seems like a super simple thing, but there's a lot of understanding about themselves, about other people, about goals and activities that they need to really completely understand in order for that to happen. Laura says actions like standing in line for the slide can be categorized as prosocial behaviors. They're actions we take to help others and to benefit the group. She decided to study what she'd seen on the playground more systematically.
这看起来是一件超级简单的事情，但其中包含着对他们自己、对其他人、对目标和活动的深刻理解，他们需要真正完全理解这些，才能让这一切发生。劳拉说，排队等滑梯这样的行为可以归类为亲社会行为。这些是我们为了帮助他人和造福集体而采取的行动。她决定更系统地研究她在游乐场上看到的情景。
She invited a bunch of parents to bring their toddlers into the lab. We were specifically testing 14 month old babies, so they're walking, they're not quite talking. These 14 month olds said bye bye to mommy and daddy, and then was strapped into front facing baby carriers worn by assistants in the study. The researchers turned on some music. Usually it was twist and shout playing in the background. And the person carrying the baby began to bounce. It was like... So we would bounce them down on one beat enough on the other, down and up sort of thing.
她邀请了一群父母把他们的幼儿带到实验室。我们具体测试的是 14 个月的婴儿，所以他们会走路，但还不太会说话。这些 14 个月的婴儿对爸爸妈妈说拜拜，然后被固定在研究助理胸前佩戴的前向婴儿背带里。研究人员播放了一些音乐。背景音乐通常是《扭转与呐喊》。背着婴儿的人开始上下晃动。就像……所以我们会按照一个节拍把他们往下晃，再按另一个节拍往上晃，就这样上下晃动。
So if you're this baby, you're strapped onto someone's chest. You can't see their face. Instead, you're looking in front of you at another assistant. The person facing the baby would either move in synchrony with how they were being bounced, so they were bouncing together, or they would move either too quickly or too slowly, so that their movements weren't aligned with what the baby was experiencing. After about two and a half minutes, the bouncing stopped, and the baby was removed from the carrier.
所以如果你是这个婴儿，你被绑在某人的胸前。你看不到他们的脸。相反，你正看着面前的另一位助理。面向婴儿的那个人要么会随着被晃动的节奏同步移动，也就是他们一起晃动，要么会移动得太快或太慢，以至于他们的动作与婴儿所体验的不一致。大约两分半钟后，晃动停止了，婴儿被从背带中抱了出来。
And then this person who had faced them and moved either in or out of sync with them would perform some little simple social games with them. So she would do things like job pictures with markers or throw paper balls in a bucket. Every now and then, the assistant who had faced the baby would drop a marker or paper ball and then pretend like the object was out of reach. So she would reach pathetically for them for about 30 seconds and we looked to see what the babies did in this really weird situation where this person they just met needs help, but isn't really asking for help and doesn't really seem to be able to achieve their
然后，这个一直面对着他们、动作与他们同步或不同步的人，会和他们玩一些简单的小社交游戏。比如她会用马克笔画画，或者把纸球扔进桶里。时不时地，面对婴儿的那位助理会掉落一支马克笔或纸球，然后假装这个物体够不着了。于是她会可怜巴巴地伸手去够大约 30 秒，我们观察婴儿在面对这种非常奇怪的情况时会有什么反应——这个他们刚认识的人需要帮助，但并没有真正开口求助，而且看起来似乎无法靠自己达成目标。
goal on their own. Laura measured how many babies would pick up and hand back the objects. And looked at whether the babies who were bounced in sync with helped at a different rate than the babies we bounced out of sync with. She found that babies who felt that they were bouncing in sync with a dance partner were more likely to help that partner pick up an object when it was out of reach. It was remarkable. So they would help on over half of the trials if we moved in sync with them. Whereas if we moved out of sync with them, they would help on only less than a third of the trials.
劳拉统计了有多少婴儿会捡起并递回这些物体。并观察了与婴儿同步晃动的人是否能让婴儿以不同的频率提供帮助，而与我们不同步晃动的婴儿则不然。她发现，那些觉得自己与舞伴同步晃动的婴儿，当舞伴够不着物体时，更有可能帮助舞伴捡起物体。这太了不起了。因此，如果我们与他们同步移动，他们会在过半的试验中提供帮助。而如果我们与他们不同步移动，他们在不到三分之一的试验中才会提供帮助。
You've likely experienced the same drive if you've ever moved in sync with someone else, maybe on a sports team in school or in marching band, or maybe like Laura, as a dancer. Be out. Guest, be out guest. Put our service to the test. Or maybe like Laura as a dancer. This song was a soundtrack of Laura's last recital in high school, which you dressed up as Mrs. Parts for a performance of Beauty and the Beast. There were many numbers in the performance, but in the B.R. guest performance, everyone comes together
如果你曾经与其他人同步移动过，比如在学校的运动队里，或者在军乐队里，或者像劳拉一样作为一个舞者，你很可能也体验过这种驱动力。做客，做客。检验我们的服务。或者也许就像劳拉一样作为一个舞者。这首歌是劳拉高中最后一场汇演的背景音乐，当时她在《美女与野兽》的演出中打扮成茶壶太太。演出中有许多曲目，但在“做客”表演中，大家齐聚一堂
all the little kitchen utensils and everything. And we do have to really synchronize at certain parts of the dance. And so when you're experiencing that, you really feel like you're part of this bigger group. And I mean, you're focusing on the task at hand, doing all of these steps, but that's become quite automatic at this point, and instead you can really sort of feel the connection
所有的小厨房用具等等。在舞蹈的某些部分，我们确实需要真正地保持同步。所以当你体验到这一点时，你真的会觉得自己是这个更大集体的一部分。我的意思是，你专注于手头的任务，做着所有的这些动作，但到了这一点，这已经变得相当自动化了，相反，你真的可以感受到与舞伴的连接，
with your code answers, and you start to just ignore the audience completely because you're part of this bigger thing. Come on and lift your glass, you want your own free pass to be our guest if you're stressed. Laura's fellow dancers remain some of her closest friends to this day. I'm going to be the MC at one of their weddings in September. So yeah, we've definitely
而且你开始完全忽略观众，因为你是这个宏大事物的一部分。来吧，举起你的杯子，如果你感到压力，你会想要一张成为我们座上宾的免费通行证。劳拉的舞伴至今仍是她最要好的朋友。今年九月，我将担任他们其中一人婚礼的司仪。所以是的，我们确实一直保持着非常紧密的联系。
stayed very close. Music and dance create bonds because, as Laura says, synchronous movement is a language of its own. This unspoken language can guide behavior even though many of us are not familiar with its syntax and vocabulary. I think music is providing a really interesting context where a lot of social cues are happening. So when we're moving with other people, when we're doing familiar things and singing familiar songs, these are actually queuing us, babies and adults to think about the relationships that we have with these people.
音乐和舞蹈创造了纽带，因为正如劳拉所说，同步的动作本身就是一种语言。尽管我们许多人并不熟悉它的句法和词汇，但这种无声的语言可以指导行为。我认为音乐提供了一个非常有趣的背景，其中发生了许多社会线索。因此，当我们与其他人一起移动时，当我们做熟悉的事情和唱熟悉的歌时，这些其实都在提示我们——无论是婴儿还是成年人——去思考我们与这些人之间的关系。
We think about teaching our kids to be pro-social and to be good citizens, but they're already attending to this information from a really early age. The toddler experiment also shows that kids who can speak are still hungry to communicate. When a small child reaches out to pick up a marker or a paper ball, she may be saying, I like you. I want to help you. Let's be friends. I find babies are so impressive. We can't really ask them what they're thinking. We have to come up with clever ways of figuring out what's going on in their little brains and everybody of underestimates them. Music and dance aren't the only ways adults and small kids communicate with one another.
我们考虑教导我们的孩子们要具有亲社会性，要做一个好公民，但他们从很小的时候就已经在关注这些信息了。幼儿实验还表明，会说话的孩子依然渴望交流。当一个小孩子伸手去拿马克笔或纸球时，她可能在说：我喜欢你。我想帮帮你。我们做朋友吧。我发现婴儿非常令人惊叹。我们无法真正问他们在想什么。我们必须想出聪明的办法，来弄清楚他们的小脑瓜里在想些什么，而每个人都低估了他们。音乐和舞蹈并不是成年人和幼儿互相交流的唯一方式。
There's another language that actually sounds a lot like language. I like that language. The traditional way of looking at babbling, even as recently as 15, 20 years ago, was really that it was just motor practice that it had no bearing on later language. It was just something babies did to exercise their mouths. This is Rachel Albert. I'm an assistant professor of psychology at Leibniz Valley College in Annville, Pennsylvania. She studies infant language development. Those quote-unquote traditional views on babbling? R-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r this optimal state of being ready to learn. Over and above, then if they were just quietly looking at an object.
还有另一种语言，听起来真的很像语言。我喜欢那种语言。对于婴儿咿呀学语的传统看法，甚至就在 15、20 年前，其实也只是认为这是一种肌肉练习，对后期的语言没有任何影响。这只是婴儿用来锻炼嘴巴的一种行为。这是蕾切尔·阿尔伯特。我是宾夕法尼亚州安维尔莱巴嫩山谷学院的心理学助理教授。她研究婴儿语言发展。那些关于咿呀学语的所谓传统观点……这种处于随时准备学习的最佳状态。甚至超过了他们只是静静地看着一个物体的时候。
Rachel says Babbles have a certain june c'est quoi? Bonjour tout-être tous, je m'appelle Madame Macron. When she hears a baby Babble, she's taken back to high school French class. And I had one of those immersive French teachers who would only speak French in the classroom. And so it was really like being dropped into a non-native environment where you have to kind of figure things out. I vividly remember that she would come into the classroom and she would start talking and the whole class
蕾切尔说，咿呀学语有一种独特的魅力？当她听到婴儿咿呀学语时，她被带回了高中的法语课。我有一位那种沉浸式教学的法语老师，她在课堂上只说法语。所以这真的就像被扔进了一个非母语的环境中，你必须自己摸索着弄懂事情。我清晰地记得，她走进教室开始说话时，全班同学在她滔滔不绝的时候，
would kind of have like stairs of panic as she would go. And so she'd start slowing down her speech and pointing and labeling particular objects in the room. So she would in French be kind of pointing and saying, you know, are you sitting in a desk? Look at the desk. Here's a desk. And kind of repeating those key vocabulary words until we started to figure out, oh, okay, this is the word for desk. Bi-o-ro, bi-o-ro, bi-o-ro. And I thought, well, this must be somewhat similar to what a baby experiences, right?
脸上都会挂着恐慌的表情。于是她开始放慢语速，指着并说出房间里特定物体的名称。所以她会在法语中指着并说，你知道的，你坐在课桌里吗？看这张桌子。这里有一张桌子。并且不断重复那些核心词汇，直到我们开始弄明白，哦，好吧，这就是桌子的意思。我认为，这一定和婴儿所经历的有些相似，对吧？
Where there's all this conversation going around. Blah, blah, blah. They start to become active communication partners and trying to engage in that world, but how do they make sense of it? Parents often see themselves as the know-it-all French teacher and the babbling baby as a clumsy student. Rachel says this framework is the one that's mostly used in studying infant language development. But the baby is applying as much of a role in this interaction as the
周围充斥着各种各样的对话。巴拉，巴拉，巴拉。他们开始成为积极的交流伙伴，并试图融入那个世界，但他们是如何理解这一切的呢？父母经常把自己看作无所不知的法语老师，而把咿呀学语的婴儿看作笨拙的学生。蕾切尔说，这种框架最常用于研究婴儿语言发展。但婴儿在这场互动中发挥的作用和妈妈一样多。
mom. By changing the way that they babble and what they're looking at, might actually be changing their opportunities for learning because they're changing what the parents say. It's kind of what we call a social feedback loop. So when the baby babbles, mom responds, the way mom responds actually will change in real time what the child says next. And they go around and around in this conversation
通过改变他们咿呀学语的方式以及他们注视的东西，实际上可能会改变他们学习的机会，因为他们改变了父母所说的话。这正是我们所谓的社交反馈循环。因此，当婴儿咿呀学语时，妈妈会做出回应，妈妈回应的方式实际上会实时改变孩子接下来所说的话。他们在这场对话中周而复始地互相影响。
influencing each other. There's a word to describe a back and forth exchange, where the thing that one person says affects what another person says. This feedback loop of communication and learning is what we call language. Baby's make as many as a thousand vocalizations every day. On average, parents respond to about 60% of these babbles. Even just silently responding, if the mom just acknowledges the infant's vocalization with a touch, leans in smiles and touches the baby, The infant will immediately, within the span of just 10 minutes, start to produce more speech-like vocalizations. So that just that nonverbal feedback,
有一个词用来描述来回的交流，即一个人说的话会影响另一个人说的话。这种交流与学习的反馈循环就是我们所说的语言。婴儿每天会发出多达一千次的发音。平均而言，父母会对其中大约 60% 的咿呀学语做出回应。甚至只是无声地回应，如果妈妈只是通过触摸来确认婴儿的发音，身体前倾微笑并触摸婴儿，婴儿就会立刻在短短 10 分钟内，开始产生更多类似语言的发音。因此，仅仅是那种非语言的反馈，那种对婴儿发音的确认，就会即时改变他们咿呀学语的方式。
that acknowledgement of the baby's vocalization, changes in the moment how they're babbling. Rachel says that when babies are babbling, they are more receptive to new information. Parents can take advantage of this by having conversations with their baby. And one rule of being a good conversationalist, stay attentive to what your partner is saying. So parents that are just talking constantly about irrelevant things that aren't what their
蕾切尔说，当婴儿咿呀学语时，他们对新信息的接受能力更强。父母可以通过与婴儿对话来利用这一点。作为一个好的对话者的一个原则是：对你的伴侣所说的话保持专注。因此，那些总是滔滔不绝地谈论一些不相干的事情、而这些事情并不是他们的孩子正在看的东西的父母……
child is looking at. For example, if a baby is looking at a ball and I'm talking about this cup over here that I'm playing with, well, you're actually providing mismatching communication, mismatching information for them, that's going to make it harder to learn. Rachel says if you listen closely, babbling often falls into four distinct categories. They have different sounds and they elicit different responses. The first type is called QRV. QRV is the least mature infant vocalization. So the sounds are quasi-resident vocalization.
例如，如果婴儿正在看一个球，而我在谈论我正在玩的这只杯子，那么你实际上是在为他们提供不匹配的交流、不匹配的信息，这会使他们更难学习。蕾切尔说，如果你仔细倾听，咿呀学语通常分为四个不同的类别。它们有不同的声音，并且会引发不同的反应。第一种类型称为 QRV。QRV 是最不成熟的婴儿发音。所以这些声音是类共鸣发音（quasi-resident vocalization）。
And so it's those really nasal-creaky sounds that a lot of times parents interpret almost as fussing. The second type is called F-R-V. So that's a fully-resident vowel. And around three or four months, the baby's vocal track opens up and then they're able to produce those more open kind of adult-like sounding vowels that kind of have those O's or A quality and so parents recognize those as more speech-like than those first creaky nasalized vowels and so they're more likely to respond to those. The third is called MSFR.
所以这些是非常具有鼻音和嘎吱声的声音，很多时候父母几乎将其解释为烦躁不安。第二种类型称为 FRV。也就是完全共鸣元音。在大约三四个月大时，婴儿的声道打开了，然后他们能够发出那些更开放的、类似成年人发音的元音，这些元音带有一点“O”或“A”的音质，所以父母认为这些比最初那些带嘎吱声的鼻化元音更像语言，因此他们更有可能对这些做出回应。第三种类型称为 MSFR。
So that's a marginal syllable, and babies will start around six or so months throwing consonants into the mix. So you can hear in that sound there's kind of a DJ kind of zh sound, but it's a slow drawn out transition between when the continent stops and when the vowel begins. And the pinnacle. The piesta resistance, if you will. So that's what's called a canonical syllable. And those are those nice babas and dadas that parents naturally associate with babbling. And so babies start regularly producing those pretty frequently around nine months. And parents react very strongly to these canonical syllables.
也就是边缘音节，婴儿在大约六个月左右开始将辅音加入其中。所以你可以从那个声音中听到一种类似 DJ 的“zh”音，但这是一种缓慢拖长的过渡，发生在辅音停止和元音开始之间。还有最高峰。也就是所谓的压轴好戏（pièce de rèsistance），如果你愿意这么称呼的话。这就是所谓的典型音节（canonical syllable）。这些就是父母自然而然地与咿呀学语联系起来的那些美妙的“巴巴”和“达达”。因此，婴儿在大约九个月大时开始定期且相当频繁地发出这些声音。父母对这些典型音节的反应非常强烈。
They hear them as the most speech-like. They tend to often interpret them as approximations of words. So, you know, in that example, if a baby was holding a ball, a mom would be very likely to respond, oh, oh, that's a ball? Yep, you're right, that's a ball. You tried to say ball, that's great. To Rachel, these different vocalizations are endlessly fascinating. Oh, oh, that's a ball, yep, you're right, that's a ball, you tried to say ball, that's great. To Rachel, these different vocalizations are endlessly fascinating. Now that she knows how to telepath the QRVs, from the FRVs, and the MSFRs, from the canonical
他们听起来这些声音最像语言。他们往往经常将其解释为对词语的近似模仿。所以，你知道的，在那个例子中，如果婴儿手里拿着一个球，妈妈很有可能会回应：“哦，哦，那是一个球？是的，你说得对，那是一个球。你试着说球，这太棒了。”对蕾切尔来说，这些不同的发音有着无尽的吸引力。哦，哦，那是一个球，是的，你说得对，那是一个球，你试着说球，这太棒了。对蕾切尔来说，这些不同的发音有着无尽的吸引力。既然她已经知道如何区分 QRV、FRV、MSFR 和典型音节，她就完全停不下来了。
syllables, she simply can't stop herself. On my wedding day, I remember very distinctly, I was in graduate school the time and knee-deep encoding this all the time, spending hours listening to these different sounds. And I remember being up at the front of the church about to say my vows and hearing some babies out in the audience, babble and kind of immediately coding it and going, oh, that was a marginal syllable. And then thinking, no, focus, this is a very important moment you're supposed to be attending to what you're past your saying,
在我的婚礼那天，我记得非常清楚，我当时正在读研究生，满脑子都在做这方面的编码，花了好几个小时听这些不同的声音。我记得当时站在教堂前面，正准备宣读誓言，却听到观众席里有些婴儿在咿呀学语，然后我本能地开始在脑海中进行编码，心想：“哦，那是一个边缘音节。”然后又想：“不，集中注意力，这是一个非常重要的时刻，你应该专注于你的牧师在说什么，”
but I couldn't help but have my attention pulled by the baby in the audience and trying to code what she was saying. You don't have to memorize all the jargon to take away something valuable from the research. Just knowing that when babies are babbling, they're ready to learn, that can be a useful takeaway for everyone. When we return, we discuss two final elements of baby language. One is going to make you very happy.
但我还是忍不住被观众席里的婴儿吸引了注意力，并试图去编码她在说什么。你不需要记住所有的行话，也能从这项研究中获得有价值的收获。只要知道当婴儿在咿呀学语时，他们就准备好学习了，这对每个人来说都是一个有用的收获。当我们回来时，我们将讨论婴儿语言的最后两个元素。其中一个会让你非常高兴。
The other? Well, that's something you don't want to hear as you're saying your wedding boughs. A warning. If you're driving or listening to the story as you're cooking, you're about to hear something very distracting. This is Katrina Doudna of Sunnyvale, California. It's dinner time. She's throwing a tantrum because she wants to sit at the head of the table. Problem is, the table's round. There is no head. When she was in the midst of a tantrum,
另一个？嗯，那绝对是你宣读婚礼誓言时最不想听到的东西。一个警告。如果你正在开车，或者一边做饭一边听这个故事，你马上就会听到一些非常让人分心的事情。这是来自加利福尼亚州桑尼韦尔的卡特里娜·道德纳。现在是晚饭时间。她正在发脾气，因为她想坐在桌子的首位。问题是，桌子是圆的。根本没有首位。当她大发脾气的时候，
she picked something that she knew was completely unreasonable. I don't want my feet. Take my feet off. I don't want my feet. I don't want my feet. That's Katrina's mom, Noemi. She says three-year-old Katrina used to throw tantrums all the time.
她挑了一件她明知完全不合理的事情。我不要我的脚。把我的脚拿走。我不要我的脚。我不要我的脚。那是卡特里娜的妈妈，诺埃米。她说三岁的卡特里娜过去常常一直发脾气。
I once teased her, which is a turn out to be a big mistake, but I went and said, well, okay, let's go get some scissors and take care of your feet. No! My curiosity was focused on what are the elements of the tantrums, you know, the snips and snails and puppy dog tails or what. This is Mike. It's Mike Potegal. I am currently an associate professor in the program on Occupational Therapy at University of Minnesota.
我有一次取笑了她，结果证明这是一个巨大的错误，但我走过去说，好吧，那我们去拿把剪刀把你的脚处理掉吧。不要！我的好奇心集中在脾气发作的组成部分是什么，你知道的，是剪刀、蜗牛、小狗尾巴还是别的什么。这是迈克。我是迈克·波特加尔。我目前是明尼苏达大学职业疗法项目的副教授。
Mike was inspired to study tantrums after witnessing his own daughters, operatic meltdowns. Among the things that I learned from that was that there was a sequence in which various behaviors appeared, various behaviors of which tantrums are composed. Just like Rachel Albert did with babbling, Mike picked out a rhythm in the cacophony of his daughter's tantrums. To prove his point, he teamed up with a colleague, James Green, he's a psychologist at the University
迈克在目睹了自己的女儿们戏剧性的崩溃之后，受到了启发去研究发脾气。我从中学到的一件事是，各种行为出现时是有先后顺序的，构成发脾气的各种行为也是如此。就像蕾切尔·阿尔伯特对咿呀学语所做的那样，迈克从女儿发脾气的喧闹声中挑出了一种节奏。为了证明他的观点，他与一位同事詹姆斯·格林合作，詹姆斯是康涅狄格大学的心理学家。
of Connecticut. We developed a onesie that toddlers can wear that has a high quality wireless microphone sewn into it. Parents put this onesie on the child and press a go button on the equipment. And then they waited for a meltdown. James and Mike recorded more than a hundred of them and what they found confirmed their hypothesis. There are two major emotional, I think of them as emotional behavioral components of tantrums.
我们开发了一款连体衣，幼儿可以穿它，上面缝有一个高质量的无线麦克风。父母把这件连体衣穿在孩子身上，然后按下设备上的启动按钮。接着他们就在等待崩溃的发生。詹姆斯和迈克记录了一百多次这样的情况，他们的发现证实了他们的假设。我认为发脾气有两个主要的感情、情绪行为组成部分。
The first is anger, hitting, kicking, screaming, throwing things, pushing and pulling. And the other component is distress. Wining, crying, throwing the self down that is dropping to the floor, and comfort seeking. Don't confuse these components with stages. Mike says the behaviors occur simultaneously. The distress is more consistent. Throughout the tantrum, from its beginning to its end. The anger punctuates the tantrum. It provides the dramatic spikes and it also tapers toward the end. In every case the anger terminates before the distress. Mike says there's a reason that most tantrums end with a distress call.
第一部分是愤怒：打人、踢人、尖叫、扔东西、推搡和拉扯。另一个组成部分是痛苦。哭闹、大哭、把自己扔在地上（也就是摔倒在地上）以及寻求安慰。不要把这些组成部分与阶段混淆。迈克说这些行为是同时发生的。痛苦的情绪表现得更为持续。贯穿整个发脾气的过程，从开始到结束。愤怒则点缀在发脾气之中。它提供了戏剧性的高峰，并且在接近尾声时逐渐减弱。在所有情况下，愤怒都在痛苦结束之前终止。迈克说，大多数发脾气都以痛苦的呼喊结束是有原因的。
Because the distress, sadness, tends to elicit comfort giving and so it would make sense from an evolutionary perspective if the anger which is disruptive is smoothed over by the stress component which then other things equal will call for parent comforting the child. Let's go back to Katrina Doudna, a three-year-old Maestra who's throwing a fit because she can't sit at the head of the family's circular dining table. Dad tries to reason with her.
因为痛苦和悲伤往往会引发关爱和安慰，所以从进化的角度来看，如果具有破坏性的愤怒被痛苦这一成分所抚平，那么在其他条件相同的情况下，这就会促使父母去安慰孩子，这是合乎情理的。让我们回到三岁的“大师”卡特里娜·道德纳身上，她正在大发脾气，因为她不能坐在家里圆形餐桌的正首位。爸爸试图和她讲道理。
James Green says that he's fallen into the same trap before. When children are at the peak of anger, and they're screaming, and they're kicking, probably asking questions, might prolong that period of anger. Dad decides to intervene. I'm going to take you in this chair for you. Now Katrina's on the floor. She grabs a stool and slams it against the wall. It seems like things are escalating, but James says it's just the opposite. Once she's thrown herself on the floor and thrown something or in this case knock the chair against the wall. We're probably on the downslope of this tantrum. She's spent a lot of energy screaming yelling and now doing these physical behaviors.
詹姆斯·格林说他以前也陷入过同样的陷阱。当孩子们处于愤怒的顶峰，在尖叫和踢打时，如果去问问题，可能会延长那段愤怒的时间。爸爸决定介入。我要把你抱到这张椅子上。现在卡特里娜躺在地上。她抓起一张凳子，狠狠地摔在墙上。事情似乎在升级，但詹姆斯说恰恰相反。一旦她把自己摔在地上并扔了东西，或者在这个例子中把椅子砸向墙壁。我们可能已经处在这个发脾气过程的下坡路上了。她已经花了很多力气尖叫、大喊，现在又做出了这些身体动作。
Listen to Katrina and pay attention to how the register of her voice changes. Mike says in many cases, parents can safely ignore their child's tantrums. And this approach has a formal name planned ignoring, and it basically means turning your back on the child and walking out of the room. Because talking to them and telling them to stop is giving them attention, albeit negative attention. This works best when the child throws a tantrum to get attention, or because you've said no to eating cookies at dinner. But if the child throws a tantrum and responds to something
听听卡特里娜的声音，注意她声音的音调是如何变化的。迈克说，在许多情况下，父母可以安全地忽略孩子发脾气。这种方法有一个正式的名称叫计划忽视（planned ignoring），它基本上意味着背对孩子并走开房间。因为对他们说话并告诉他们停下来就是在给他们关注，尽管是负面关注。当孩子发脾气是为了引起注意，或者因为你拒绝了他们在晚餐时吃饼干的要求时，这种方法效果最好。但如果孩子发脾气是对你要求他们做的事情做出反应，
you've asked them to do, a very different approach is appropriate. And the reason for that is that what the tantrum does is it's basically a stall. It's a way for the child to not comply with the parent request. And so the best approach, if it can be managed, is to get the child to comply with the request. For younger children, this can be done with a hand over hand, a kind of forced cooperation. So you can say to the child, okay, get your PJs on, and if the child refuses, you can say, okay, I'm going to count to three or five or whatever you like. And if you have not begun putting
那么一种截然不同的方法才是合适的。这样做的原因是，发脾气实际上是一种拖延。这是孩子不服从父母要求的一种方式。因此，如果能够做到的话，最好的方法是让孩子服从要求。对于年龄较小的孩子，可以通过手把手的方式来做到这一点，这是一种强制合作。所以你可以对孩子说，好了，把你的睡衣穿上，如果孩子拒绝，你可以说，好吧，我要数到三或五，随你喜欢。如果你还没有开始穿
your PJs on, I'm going to put my hands on your hands and help you do it. And children really do not like this. Because he says it's a threat to their autonomy, and if the child still doesn't comply, maybe you can use it as an opportunity to do some research, just like Mike. We would walk down the street and I'd see a kid having a tantrum and I would say I would mutter or say out loud to my wife, Dato, and then of course you'd give me a side-long look about what's wrong with you.
睡衣，我会把我的手放在你的手上，帮你把它穿上。孩子们真的很讨厌这样。因为他说这是对他们自主权的威胁，如果孩子仍然不服从，也许你可以把它当作一个做研究的机会，就像迈克一样。我们走在街上，我看到一个小孩在发脾气，我会喃喃自语或者大声对我的妻子说：“Dato（发脾气）”，然后她当然会斜眼看我，心想你脑子有什么毛病。
We've talked so far about the secret languages of dancing and babbling. We've looked at the grammar of temper tantrums. We're getting close to the end of our story, and that brings us to Lala Bice. Laura Cerelli, the first researcher we featured on dancing and synchronization, has also done work on the language of music with infants. Across cultures, we all engage with music and we do it at such an early age. So we really wanted to continue to explore this idea that one of the real benefits and perhaps one of the underlying reasons why we invest so much time in energy and music across cultures is because of these social and emotional implications. Remember the magic of the cleanup song that Laura talked about earlier? She and her fellow researchers wanted to closely examine the effect of music on babies and their caregivers.
到目前为止，我们已经讨论了舞蹈和咿呀学语的秘密语言。我们研究了发脾气的语法。我们离故事的尾声越来越近了，这把我们带到了催眠曲。劳拉·塞雷利，我们介绍的第一位研究舞蹈和同步性的研究人员，也对婴儿的音乐语言进行了研究。跨越文化，我们所有人都参与音乐，而且我们在很小的年纪就开始了。所以我们真的很想继续探讨这个观点，即跨文化投入大量时间和精力在音乐中的真正好处之一，也许也是潜在原因之一，正是因为这些社会和情感意义。还记得劳拉之前谈到的收拾玩具歌的魔力吗？她和她的研究同事想要仔细研究音乐对婴儿及其照顾者的影响。
They asked parents to volunteer to come into the lab with their babies. 30 mothers said they would do it. They would be in a sound proof room, and babies would be sat in a little high chair, and moms would sit facing them. They were also measuring stress levels. So we used little stickers on the bottom of the baby's foot and on the mother's fingertips. And what we're able to measure with this is actually their sweat gland activity. The mother is then sang two versions of Twinkle Twinkle Little Star, one version, was upbeat. The other.
他们邀请父母自愿带着婴儿来到实验室。30 位母亲表示愿意参与。她们将待在一个隔音房间里，婴儿坐在一个小小的高脚椅上，妈妈们坐在他们对面。他们还在测量压力水平。所以我们在婴儿脚底和妈妈指尖贴了小贴纸。我们通过这个能够测量的是他们的汗腺活动。然后妈妈唱了两首不同版本的《小星星》，一个版本是欢快的。另一个版本是。
What's a lullaby? What we found was that when mom sang in a playful way, both mom and babies arousal levels stayed stable. But when mom sang in a soothing way, both mom and babies arousal levels decreased as the song progressed. So what's this, this is telling us is that lullabies are really working to calm not only baby, but also the mother. And so this supports this idea that there's a function here.
什么是催眠曲？我们发现，当妈妈用嬉戏的方式唱歌时，妈妈和婴儿的唤醒水平都保持稳定。但当妈妈用舒缓的方式唱歌时，随着歌曲的推进，妈妈和婴儿的唤醒水平都下降了。所以这说明了什么？这告诉我们，催眠曲不仅能有效地安抚婴儿，也能安抚妈妈。因此，这支持了这里存在某种功能的观点。
Is this telling us just what, is it just confirming what our intuitions are telling us? Or do you think it's telling us something more than that? Annick Dolly I'm sure most parents would agree that will abide suit their babies. But usually when we're singing will abise to our babies, we're holding them and we're rocking them and we're adding all of this really important soothing tactile information. So we wanted to know what the song is doing, removing all of that tactile input. So the babies are sitting in the high chair, they're facing their mom, but they're not experiencing that holding and that rocking, that typically comes along with all the bias.
这只是在说明什么，它只是证实了我们的直觉吗？还是你认为它说明了更多的事情？安尼克·多利，我相信大多数父母都会同意催眠曲适合他们的婴儿。但通常当我们对婴儿唱催眠曲时，我们会抱着他们、摇晃他们，并加入所有这些非常重要的舒缓的触觉信息。所以我们想知道，剥离了所有这些触觉输入后，单靠歌曲本身能起到什么作用。因此，婴儿坐在高脚椅上，面对着妈妈，但他们没有体验到通常伴随催眠曲而来的那种拥抱和摇晃。
But I think the really interesting thing here is we usually think of that unidirectional relationship like when mom's saying to babies it is to change the baby's behavior, but I think it's the really new interesting thing here is considering how it's also affecting the mom. Indeed, if there's one thing that all this research shows is that communicating with babies is not a one-way street. Parents and caregivers are shaped by what babies say and sing and scream, just as babies are hungrily soaking up information from adults. When we think about raising a human, it's natural that most of us think about the role that adults play in shaping their children. What's less clear, but what is abundantly true, is that babies
但我认为这里真正有趣的事情是，我们通常认为那种关系是单向的，比如妈妈对婴儿唱歌是为了改变婴儿的行为，但我认为这里真正新颖有趣的是，考虑它也是如何影响妈妈的。确实，如果所有这些研究表明了一件事，那就是与婴儿交流绝不是单向的。父母和照顾者被婴儿所说、所唱、所尖叫的内容所塑造，正如婴儿从成年人那里如饥似渴地汲取信息一样。当我们考虑抚养一个人时，我们大多数人很自然地会想到成年人在塑造孩子方面所扮演的角色。不那么显眼、但却极其真实的是，婴儿
are every bit is involved in raising humans of their own. It's not just a figure of speech, we're all always growing up. This week's show was produced by Parth Shah and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu and Laura Quarell. We like to end our podcast by acknowledging an unsung hero each week. This is usually a person who is working behind the scenes who helps us create the show. Since this episode is dropping right around Mother's Day, we want to recognize all the mothers of the Hidden Brain team.
在抚养他们自己的成年人这方面也同样参与其中。这不仅仅是一个比喻，我们所有人其实都在不断成长。本周的节目由帕思·沙（Parth Shah）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）剪辑。我们的团队成员包括雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）和劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）。我们喜欢在每期播客结束时感谢一位幕后英雄。这通常是一个在幕后工作、帮助我们创作节目的人。由于本节目的发布时间正好在母亲节前后，我们要向 Hidden Brain 团队的所有母亲致敬。
Watzala, Melanie, Dorothea, Bella, Toby and Linda. Thank you for your work in raising us humans. You truly have made Hidden Brain possible. Today's episode is part of an NPR-wide project called How to Raise a Human. You can find more stories about parenting at npr.org. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is... AHHHHH! AHHHHH! AHHHHH! AHHHHH! AHHHHH! AHHHHH! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
瓦扎拉（Watzala）、梅兰妮（Melanie）、多萝西亚（Dorothea）、贝拉（Bella）、托比（Toby）和琳达（Linda）。感谢你们在抚养我们人类方面所做的工作。你们确实让 Hidden Brain 成为可能。今天的节目是 NPR 全台项目《如何抚养一个人》（How to Raise a Human）的一部分。你可以在 npr.org 上找到更多关于育儿的故事。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是……啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。